what's up guys this is Jordan welcome
back to the channel as you can see I
finally shaved my mustache so I'm no
longer getting a ton of dirty looks from
every pair of young parents that I walk
by anyways today we're going to be
talking about object stores so let's go
ahead and get right into it all right I
have whipped out the old apple pencil so
let's get started so basically in the
last video what we talked about was CDN
and cdns are effectively a nice
distributed Geographic cache for us to
go ahead and store our static content on
our application so that users can easily
see it static content meaning any type
of file that could be a video it could
be a photo music files logs anything
like that and so the gist is because CDN
are a cache we can't store everything in
there we need to actually look for a
place to put the rest of our static
content so what is actually going to be
the backup of the CDN or the source of
Truth rather well in the past we've
talked about Hadoop or hdfs Hadoop
distributed file system so let's go
ahead and do a quick recap on that and
we'll talk about whether that's the
right solution for this problem so going
and looking at the Hadoop recap
basically to remind everyone in case you
didn't watch that video if you didn't
you probably should Hadoop is a
distributed processing framework which
means that we can use a bunch of
commodity Hardware basically just random
Dell computers located in a bunch of
servers uh or rather in a bunch of data
centers to go ahead and both store files
and also run large batch processes on
these uh files because of the fact that
the compute aka the place where we're
actually going to be running those batch
jobs is local to where the files are
stored that's kind of the main value at
so you've got you know on every single
node obviously you've got some computing
power and you've also got some dis
space and the general Paradigm is that
we want to basically be sharding up our
jobs so that anywhere where there's a
file that we care about uh we're
handling it accordingly on that note
eventually we'll probably have to
shuffle some data over the network but
we want to get as much data locality as
humanly possible on Hadoop okay so
Hadoop unfortunately does actually have
some pitfalls at least when it comes to
storing just generalized static content
so the first thing is that you know if
you're actually managing a Hadoop
cluster if you're the person in charge
of literally dealing with all of these
nodes uh that is just very inconvenient
because when you need more space you
have to actually add more nodes that
could be you know spinning up an ec2
instance if you're running a dup cluster
on a bunch of cloud VMS it could be
literally adding a new physical server
node uh but either way it's just a pain
in the butt another thing is that it is
expensive so here's the thing like I
mentioned before we've got some
compute and we've got a bunch of files
and so the issue is uh generally
speaking when you're running batch jobs
you don't really know exactly uh where
the files that you care about or stored
beforehand something like spark or maper
juice would kind of handle that for you
and so as a result let's say you know
you're running some massive ml batch job
on maybe 10% of your files the other 90%
of your computers are probably still
doing nothing in this batch job and yet
they're storing a bunch of different
files and they're still holding very
expensive graphics cards that are just
not getting used so the point is is that
Hardware or rather specifically uh
compute and
disk are scaling
linearly I can't spell today I don't
know why and the issue with that is that
it's expensive because a lot of the time
we don't necessarily want to run big
batch jobs we just want to throw a bunch
of stuff somewhere and if we need to we
can always read it back later but it's
not super important that we have some
either specialty Hardware or just good
Hardware in general sometimes we
literally just want more hard
drives so this is kind of where object
stores come in this is a major service
offered by large Cloud providers AKA
just big tech companies so Amazon Google
Microsoft are probably the biggest three
object stores that you'd have heard of
if you've heard of S3 Azure cloud
storage Google Cloud Storage so what are
the main advantages of these well uh
they're just easy to use use number one
is you don't actually have to have any
estimate of the number of files that you
need to store or the capacity that you
need it pretty much autosales for you
which is important the other thing is
that you know you can just configure how
many replicas you want it'll deal with
that for you I would love to do a deep
dive into the architecture of things
like object stores but the truth is
because these are all proprietary um you
can't really look into exactly how they
work I imagine there's some sort of like
Network shared storage and then you know
you just have a ton of nodes in there
too with really crappy CPUs but either
way they're able to make this thing
super cheap and that is kind of the main
point so I looked at some article from
data breaks I'll throw this in the
description of the video but it looks
like to store the same amount of data on
some Hadoop cluster that you're running
on AWS versus just dedicated S3 uh it's
about a tenth of the price which is
really wild if you think about it and so
you basically end up getting this black
box right here which is called an object
store and you can throw anything in
there logs images blah blah blah blah
blah and so actually what this is kind
of leg to is a bunch of companies will
do this and what they'll call it is a
data lake so if you've heard of this
term before basically think of it in
contrast to a data warehouse we've
spoken about a data warehouse before on
this channel where a data warehouse has
a schema it's explicitly basically just
like a massive SQL table for a lot of
analytical processing it probably uses
column oriented storage and it's got a
bunch of mini tables together all with a
schema that we can join and So that
obviously is going to require some
amount of pre-processing or pre-
formatting of the data whereas the kind
of the main appeal of a data lake is
that in a massive company you've got
tons of files that are being generated
tons of different logs tons of different
data and you're probably not going to
want to have to you know get that in
some agreed upon schema beforehand it
would be better to just put it in one
centralized repository and then deal
with it later through a variety of batch
jobs and so that is all schema and
that's effectively what an object store
can do for you and this is colloquially
been dubbed as a data lake so you see it
can include logs or metrics or images or
really anything else you can just put it
in there and this is great especially
when you have many teams within a
company because then some other team can
dig it out after the fact and do
whatever processing you need on it so
the big thing here is that that's going
to require some sort of batch jobs right
and the question is how a batch jobs
actually work on object stores because
if you recall I pretty much blatantly
said that the main appeal of object
stores are that they have a ton of
storage and not that much compute so
unfortunately the main downside of
object stores are that they aren aren't
great for running batch jobs so
basically if you have all of your data
in this Lake in S3 you're eventually
going to have to go and Export it to
some sort of distributed computing
cluster probably had doop and go ahead
and do that and that's going to be slow
because it's a lot of files you are
effectively having to put them over the
network and of course that is a
bottleneck but it seems that in reality
a lot of companies have kind of just
weighed out this trade-off and realized
that it's not a huge deal for them one
of the kind of the key defining factors
of the batch job is that you kind of
don't really care when it runs as long
as it runs by the time it has to
obviously there are some exceptions to
this uh and we can discuss those in a
little bit but as long as your batch job
gets done say within the hour within the
day or something like that it's
generally fine and if it allows you to
run a smaller Hado cluster then what you
would have been able to do otherwise it
can be a lot less expensive which for
these companies with tons of data really
makes a difference to their bottom line
hence the reason that this kind of
Paradigm is becoming a lot more popular
so in conclusion using an object store
to basically just dump everything AKA as
a data lake is actually pretty viable
you can always do batch jobs on the data
later you are going to have to move it
over the network which is unfortunate
but sometimes that's just life so even
though it is a little bit less
convenient it comes at a much lower cost
on the other hand if you do actually
have batch jobs that you need to run
with very low latency if you really want
to take advantage of the data locality
that something like Hadoop would give
you well then you may just have to use a
Hadoop cluster it's a bit more expensive
but that's kind of what happens when you
get better performance anyways guys I
hope this video makes sense as a high
level overview I will see you in the
next one